fighting between rival factions and
lebanon's largest refugee camp for
Palestinians is forcing a growing number
of them to seek safety elsewhere
Lebanese Army commanders say five
soldiers were wounded when shells fired
from the NL Harbor Camp landed nearby
five people in the camp have been killed
and dozens injured since a ceasefire
between Palestinian armed groups ended
on Friday well inel hallway is near the
southern city of Sudan it's home to
around 50 000 Palestinians who live
there in cramped conditions let's speak
to our correspondence she joins us now
from there zaina as this continues to
escalate so many have felt that they've
had no choice but to leave where are
they ending up and are they getting help
well it's a desperate situation hundreds
of families have escaped the fighting
they've left their homes in einel
Halloween others remain trapped inside
in some neighborhoods it's just too
difficult to venture out to reach you
know outside the camp we are at one
mosque very close to the camp where a
few hundred families are seeking shelter
so they're seeking shelter in mosques in
schools and the situation like I said is
desperate because these people were poor
to begin with the majority of
Palestinians in Lebanon there's an
approximately 250 000 Palestinians
between 50 to 70 000 live in einel
Halloween they are poor if they do not
work today they cannot put food on the
table they're relying on support from
local charities local ngos even the
United Nations relief and works agency
underwear which is the UN agency that is
supposed to provide them with Services
because Palestinians are denied services
and rights in Lebanon is a cash-strapped
organization even before the the latest
round of fighting they were complaining
about the lack of funding they were
complaining that they would not be able
to continue their services until the end
of the year during last month's bout to
violence they said up to 400 homes were
destroyed and they need 15.5 million
dollars to rebuild those homes and now
with this latest round of battles more
homes are being destroyed which means
they're going to indeed much more money
zaina where are we at with any kind of
mediation efforts to to try to stop the
fighting
well it's day five clashes are
continuing since that one month's truth
collapsed late on Thursday night there
have been repeated attempts to mediate a
ceasefire to implement a ceasefire on
the ground so far they have failed now
there will be a new attempt to mediate
and enter the fighting this afternoon
and what we understand is that the
Palestinian president Mahmoud Abbas his
fatah movement is at war with a number
of groups inside the camp under the
banner of the Muslim youth he has sent a
special Envoy to Lebanon azamil Ahmad he
will be attending a meeting with top
ranking Lebanese security officials as
well as representatives of lebanon's
army to discuss the possibility of
creating a joint security Force to enter
the camp to implement Law and Order to
ensure that the Assassins of a senior
fatah Commander is handed over and to
ensure that armed Fighters vacate U.N
run schools now we've heard this time
and time again will this happen it's
still unclear but both sides know that
this is not going to be an easy battle
it will be costly and it will be long
because this is a densely populated camp
where there are narrow Alleyways so it's
going to be a very difficult fight we
have to wait to see whether the latest
mediation attempt will bear any any food
later today indeed and we certainly hope
they will then with all the latest for
us from an al-halwa thank you so much